Sagen
Ich sage
Ich sage: Hallo.
Du sagst
Du sagst nichts.
Er sagt
Er sagt Quatsch.
Quatsch!
Sie sagt
Sie sagt: Aua!
Aua!
Es sagt
Es sagt mir nichts.
Wir sagen
Wir sagen: Willkommen.
Ihr sagt
Ihr sagt Tschüss.
Tschüss!
Sie sagen
Sie sagen: Auf Wiedersehen.
Auf Wiedersehen! - Auf Wiedersehen!
Machen
Ich mache
Ich mache ein Video für euch.
Du machst
Du machst mit.
Er macht
Er macht nichts.
Sie macht
Sie macht mich verrückt.
Es macht
Es macht alles keinen Sinn.
Wir machen
Wir machen etwas Geheimes.
Ihr macht
Ihr macht uns glücklich mit einem Like.
Sie machen
Sie machen Krach.
Hören
Ich höre
Ich höre Cari und Ana.
Du hörst
Du hörst mir nicht zu.
Er hört
Er hört nichts.
Sie hört
Sie hört Stimmen.
Es hört
Es hört sich gut an.
Wir hören
Wir hören Musik.
Ihr hört
Cari, Michael!
Ihr hört mich nicht.
Sie hören
Sie hören mir nicht zu.
Und jetzt seid ihr dran: In unserer App Seedlang
könnt ihr selbst interaktiv die Konjugationen
von deutschen Verben üben. Unter anderem könnt ihr dort
eure Aussprache üben und ihr könnt auf die Untertitel
draufklicken und dort Informationen zur Grammatik
und zu den Übersetzungen erhalten. Probiert es mal aus,
hier geht es direkt zu Seedlang und hier könnt ihr
Easy German abonnieren und das solltet hr unbedingt machen.
Viel Spaß und bis nächste Woche!